[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to resident
evil oh [ __ ] the lights are on
someone would be upset make sure the
point we use to the super high product
quality of Resident Knievel were thrown
off listen this is high-end stuff here
this is top quality content this is
number one hey have you seen the Blair
Witch Project yeah I want to pick the
right one she's being Mike right now
staring in the corner that's right and
then this guy is the one who screams or
possibly the which depending on your
perspective
Billy's more of a witch suite so it's a
hundred second episode Wow
I'm excited I don't remember white wine
today not just killing it where we have
a work thing what is that white wine
really I didn't bring it though that's
the joke we have a well you know you do
you drink white wine before I have a
margarita I'm more of a tequila girl
myself are you trying to shame me for
drinking Sauvignon Blanc I think you
should drink whatever you feel like I
would never drink shame now that I have
your permission I will I will admit I
did not you know put you in the basket
of white wine but it doesn't mean you
can do my girlfriend got me into it
recently I'm usually a red guy listen
don't blame your girlfriend for what you
love I'm giving her credit not blaming
her okay so you ran into those the Apes
the Eliminator Apes last time those
[ __ ] Apes yeah uh monkeys had you
been calling him let's talk about this
for a second um oh yeah I can pull up
some comments cuz there were some tips
she's not doing great
she's on coffee on you got some ammo
last time before you saved her eye yeah
it got I played Red Dead two the other
day
that's cool let's figure out where we're
going first and then tell me more so
he's actually pretty full he's got a
shotgun he's got a gun he's got what
does she got there were coming she needs
bullets I'm gonna give her these there
were comments saying you might want the
grenade launcher I don't really remember
what exactly comes next but our
commenters are usually pretty spot-on I
mean
and I got that advice as well from
another Kamini person as well and I
would like to heed their advice and that
hundred episode compilation is
officially up on YouTube there were some
container scenes but it's up it did it
went up Monday oh you should told me
which we did it oh yeah sorry that's
okay it just doesn't get that promo um
let me see what it is up so people can
see it
Nathan Shepard really is he must be an
accountant or something handgun has
accounted for over 70% of kills in this
playthrough so far can never take the
trusty sidearm for granted see that's
what I've been saying but nathan has the
numbers to back it up so cool all right
so let's let's talk a little bit mm-hmm
where are the monkeys are they in the
room with the circle no they're yeah
they're in the room right outside this
one okay so do I need to deal with them
now you'll want to kill them yeah
because you're gonna I killed them at
the end of last episode yeah and during
the spoiler section yes
so I'm just gonna do the same thing I'm
gonna get out my trusty shotgun and I'm
just gonna shoot them yeah and have
molotovs with Rebecca as well as
possible why just because they're gonna
be helpful like a sign a bunch of tips
no not spill a term on ya got it okay so
let's deal with these monkeys first uh
little crits sorry I thought it was low
last time I'm not sure sometimes it gets
we're not the only ones that you use
this room to record so sometimes
somebody comes up here and yeah funks it
up um where are you little [ __ ] oh
sorry
they're jumping that's that's your fault
Ludacris I turned the volume up for you
dye monkey oh god that's so like
gratuitous I'm trying to back up when I
ain't find you're good I can hear them
let me I'm out of shotguns sound like he
killed but I heard him yeah I thought I
was dying
Moodle is monkey poop on the floor watch
your step
did you kill one last time at third one
I killed all of them last time no no no
I sorry I mean like I only remember just
now you killing two but there's three
dead ones I didn't member you while
you're doing this well what let's talk
about what we're doing first I'm
actually not sure what I'm doing I don't
know I don't
okay well that's step one sir so we have
like a puzzle a strong prey upon the
weaker the law of the jungle I am the
king of all I survey no creature can
escape my grasp I think i'ma do side
behind him oh is this like my sharp wits
allow me to bring down even the greatest
horned beasts
no amount of cunning can match the speed
of my supple limbs that one's my
favorite
I dance freely through the air capturing
a legless prey I stand tall on the earth
with horns proudly displaying you have
to like light those sconces and creep up
on my victims and legless I conquer even
the mightiest of things with my place
okay so the eagle was talking about
snatching up a legless prey right that's
the snake sure guy rekindle the flames
of life from the spirits of the weak so
sorry what sorry rekindle the rekindle
the flames of life from the spirits of
the weak from the spirits of the weak
okay so you read a wartime rekindle the
flames of life from the spirits of the
weak so it's almost like if the bird
says it kills the snake then the bird
has to eat the snake's flame or
something I just worry that it's one of
those puzzles where you can [ __ ] up and
get like poisoned gas I mean I just
saved so I'm just gonna live it so okay
I can't use
I like don't know what to do okay I'll
with the bird so you're going in order
from strongest to weakest right now oh
I'm not asking that was a question sorry
is that what it is because how do I know
who's the weakest that's the logic part
of it like so he says her here he's the
king yeah so I used to like last no but
the the snake said you can bring down
even the king so that's like that that's
confusing oh yeah
even the mighty king so he's got to be
the cougar so is it just an order thing
it doesn't actually matter like who's
first or does it matter what it matters
who's first I think so there's nothing
unless unless you how do I undo the fire
how do i unfired do it again like what
do you mean do it again add more fire
because you'd make like the worst
fireman I show up at the building and
just [ __ ] like douse it with gasoline
maybe if you just light one more it'll
say you're wrong oh okay so just in case
if you're going from strongest do the
snake just for posterity's sake
and then it would be the Cougar because
he's talking about eating the king
right so this thing eats the snake the
snake eats this thing but this thing
says he eats everything
so what could possibly be past it so I
have to it's not gonna be the deer cuz
the the wolf said it can bring down the
tallest prey or whatever so that's the
wolf eating the deer but what's after
this guy yeah this one so it's not the
deer I think it's just deduction what
about the horse was the horse a supple
supple limbs no amount of wit or
whatever cunning yeah sorry sorry one
more time no amount of cunning can match
the speed of my supple limbs
one of them said they were smart was it
the wolf or was it this guy
no that's the tall like the wolf said he
was smart right yeah yes
so that means the wolf is under that
horse wits yeah so no amount of cunning
so he's under the horse the wolf eats
deer
so he's next no the horse and then the
wolf oh yeah we're going straight
strongest to weakest its horse than the
wolf okay wait what am I forgetting one
of them no we did serpent eagle cougar
yeah horse wolf deer you have to be like
right up in its butt hell yeah
[Music]
dear yeah I'm like if this is wrong
we'll just do the reverse order sure
because this seems very right it's wrong
right do dear dear first they make you
go through that whole [ __ ] thing
before they tell you wrong
Capcom yeah okay don't I know who we are
okay so this guy then Z wolf am I about
to do this again or is this door gonna
be permanently open I have no clue do
the wolf why the wolf because he eats
the deer
or he said like he can bring down the
pollen yeah still I am okay and then
cougar snake cougar snake are you sure
yes cuz he says he's the king and he's
just being cocky saying no one I can
bring down everybody but then the snakes
like I couldn't even bring down the King
right and the snake is legless and
yeah it's like it's trying to trick me
everything started King until they get
eaten
Louise's 16th he got eaten
JFK Jeff hey got eaten from from yeah
[ __ ] I'll be Harville yeah good job
so here's my question before I go in
here should I get the grenade I honestly
don't know okay there's two doors off
there sure but there was stuff in the
room where you save Rebecca that you
didn't do yet what do you mean in the
room you save Rebecca you guys left the
room to escape there was some there
wasn't a way to go in there that yeah I
don't know if that's necessarily what we
should do first
I don't know tried this hot one that
look like a save no that would be a
saver I doubt it like maybe there's
supplies in there or something okay we
can try I just hope it's not a boss cuz
I'm not prepared well les I'm saying the
door the end of the hall it looks more
like a boss door it does but Capcom
not bottle bottle but oh okay she can do
it
oh god did you hear that is that me was
it me yeah I think so yeah Billy's fat
feet
oh that was one of the meet three of
those yes sweet so that's our
overarching objective right now correct
where did they go though upstairs where
was that no those down here somewhere
yet there's a lot going on all right so
I don't see anything else did you see
anything else did I miss anything
Oh God unnecessary oh okay all right so
I don't think I should go to the end of
the hall okay I agree it looks ominous
that looks like remember Nosferatu from
Code Veronica the dude at the bottom of
that pit screaming that you fought yes
yes god no so funny I didn't like that
guy all right so where shall I go this
goes downstairs upstairs I think
oh no you might be right looks down some
I don't know a lot about stairs yeah
just to be safe a few people did say
bring grenades I think it might be best
to prepare to it I can put the tablet
away if we figure out where the tablets
go oh yeah sure you could just drop that
in the safe room this doesn't look good
either
I mean up on the save room what do you
mean
the save room was back there to get your
grenade long oh never mind it's not it's
a box
no okay where did these come from
oh you were sprinting through here
because Rebecca was hanging from that
ledge oh right plus the monkeys should I
get these cuz I think she has enough
room
although yeah you could bring him back
to the main room and drop them actually
they're both full or on the way back
down get it and bring it to the money to
save room if I pick it up oh no they're
they're highlighted no they're not let
me just highlight them yeah so even if I
can't pick them up they're highlighted
right uh-huh okay let me just do that so
that I don't forget never forget
wait while you're doing that yeah so uh
tom picks Tom apology if I'm butchering
that a few days ago said this show is
what makes a weekend feel like a weekend
for me so thank you for doing this I'm
working overtime so we can I have to
time to watch this before work begins
well that's good you get to watch it
sorry had to work overtime yeah that
sucks but most the time when you make
you make time and a half on OTE that's
good I know that's why my sister does it
someone I don't know what it is I just
think it's funny that you said the
stereo nomicon said handsome Mike thanks
Darryl said I liked resident knievel
same here
thank you yeah okay here we go sounds
like a tip from niko pesty May oh is it
p'tee Smitty I think this is the same
Niko that watches pretty often but has a
last name now just an FYI the grenade
rounds you got from the giant chess room
looked like incendiary rounds because it
had red colors that means you can use
them like the molotovs throw the
incendiary rounds if I'm reading that
correctly you can throw them you just
Chuck a grenade this just an FYI the
grenade rounds you got from the giant
chess room looked like incendiary rounds
because it had red colors that's crazy
that means you can use them like the
Molotov this is the main room yeah
should I head towards there yeah because
I can drop in a like I could drop items
off I get so goddamn confused in this
please back up that is where the grenade
launcher is and I can drop off some
items yeah love you guys stay evil
thanks proto uh 710 Mike please cost by
a Steve I'm Leon Chris maybe I have
bigger bicep stuff oh my god
yeah so happy to see you guys again love
these thank you honey fufu
all right so oh yeah a few people said
this mark Alyn Tolentino said you should
have examined the chemical tank using
Rebecca what chemical tank because I do
people did say that he said to get the
green chemical and combine it for later
cuz she's a chemical lady yeah that
makes sense I'm gonna leave this because
we can deal with that later do you think
the enemy is a poison enemy because I'd
rather not waste a spot on a blue herb
unless it's a poison I need to be clear
I don't know what's coming up but I get
what you're saying I don't I don't think
a blue would be and then he doesn't have
any shotgun shells so if he doesn't he
should just take the grenade launcher
thoughts that makes sense
hopefully don't run into shotgun shells
do you have Molotov you couldn't she
could take as well I have to make them
but yes let me just see what I got here
so she's got three bottles here so I was
just gonna combine it yeah with this
stuff arty gaming said give me a
shout-out please there you go what up RC
gaming combine oh sure oh god
I accidentally combine the wrong things
but it's fine Oshin correct me if I'm
saying that wrong I think it's ocean
looks like it's like Gaelic thanks for
the shoutout can't believe that only the
revelation games are left after zero I
think we'll need some silent Knievel
after the Resident Evil 2 remake
releases that would be amazing
I like Silent Hill we've been purposely
mention that to me well a lot of people
have mentioned Silent Hill
we've been I've purposely not do you
think I should save because I put all
this effort into like organizing and
managing everything you found new
increments at the end of last episode I
think yes
yeah but saving twice an episode is
always like risque well someone yeah
yeah all right so I got six here no I
mean what's the harm in bringing more oh
and the space but more importantly I
would say it's actually like do I want
to use all my grenades well if it comes
down to that or dying right
what is it Rebecca have not very much so
he only has a green herb I was gonna
when we go back through there's a red
and I was gonna grab a red and have her
combine another green in a red also
people pointed out that combining two
greens is also really good which we
should know by the first from the first
game but red and green is definitely
ideal red green blue is great so sorry
what was the decision on this I am
saving is that what we're doing I'm
going to save yeah I'm I'm on board
okay I'm gonna save because we've we
haven't really done that much but I
don't want to do all this again cuz it's
boring I don't want to watch it again so
I really don't like that they don't give
me like a billion saves I'm just reading
this comment that's actually phazon
infuser it's not a tip but it's huh okay
so he people didn't mention audio levels
were low this episode so I'll just
double check the third yeah okay so
sorry I know you're reading those but
let's let's talk about this she saved
you got your stuff so I have made you
drop that tablet yes yeah I did so she's
got 30 bullets three maltose he has nine
AIDS three multi-beam bullets yeah he
I'm gonna combine this green with a red
in the previous room and they'll both
have full heals however what red I said
however she's already on caution yeah so
it's just something to consider because
she's gonna probably have to pop a full
heal immediately if she gets hit or
right now if she gets hit yeah
I'd say don't use it yet though like I'm
agreeing with you I'd say what was that
herb are you talking about I don't I
remember a green herb in the boiler room
there's a red one too and a blue one
there's a full set the Holy Trinity if
this whole area sucks makes me seriously
anxious there level design is like
creepy
so there's the green here's a red blue
seriously yeah should I do
oh [ __ ] should I combine the blue two or
no I mean there's no negative effect to
it aside from the fact that you kind of
like wasting in exchange give it to her
change places and then yes he's very
idiot it was so close exchange give it
to him that's what we're doing correct
yeah and then should she take another
green or no probably not probably not
okay let's do it oh wait what insider
info do you have you seem so worried
about this next room and I'm I don't
have any insider info I just heard
someone say like Mohammed a fan of the
show said that coming up I'm gonna want
to be careful or take a grenade launcher
and maybe like I don't know how accurate
that is but I it is ominous viewers have
been write more frequently than I have
correct
I trust them much more than you someone
also sent me a link to what motherlover
like inspired it or like the reasoning
behind it and I favored it but I haven't
read it yet it's a queen song reference
really yeah and that's also
yeah
okay but uh disappointing considering
house concerned I have management
trainees diary what does that director
Marcus researching all the time and
what's up with his interest in beaches
yeah
well that's weird
I guess he like turned into a zombie
marry believe Mike on this episode what
happened I don't remember I think I just
probably gave you what you deserved
I feel like we have swapped I'm more
positive now I'm all I've been the same
steady marry they call me steady she
goes yeah we got Halloween coming up
named ships after me and churches and
many songs was that it that's not the oh
this is the door to the south that was
it yeah so you want to go up to where
Rebecca was hanging to the left of the
save room what was what what was the
point of going in there nothing you
weren't even gonna mention I know I was
reading I'd like to reference the
audience a lot they're our lifeblood but
you've missed the point the show I'm
good at adapting mm-hmm so what's going
on what game is this white wine makes me
think this looks sinister hmm it's
concerning
I'm taking one step at a time at least
you can like manually go up and down
stairs and it's not like you press
vaccinated I'm scared don't be scared
baby it's good the noises yeah no no no
don't go away Sam Oh what am i doing you
can so people pointed out that you don't
necessarily have they're easier to dodge
spiders so maybe go reset and then come
back through you're already kind of
going up the stairs ah [ __ ] she might
have just got you could restart you save
Kovich wait what I will go through yeah
you could restart you say if she hurt
her
now if I mean let's see how bad she is
well she lets through a the damage
okay I you could wipe and then go it
wasn't
she's not poison though right no we got
this she was gonna be interested the
spiders are not like monkey level of
annoy so just dodge them yeah sorry um
so do one person at a time so I know
they said a cardinal rule is to not
leave them alone but in this case so the
AI doesn't get [ __ ] up got it do one
at a time
that makes sense that was actually I'll
find it also Ava Cassandra commented so
happy you guys like the piece that was
so fun if you didn't watch the last
episode she's referencing the yeah the
hundred episode commemorative art as it
were really guarded by my Twitter [ __ ] I
say you wipe this is not going well it's
worth it you'll save like gonna get
killed that was so annoying it's just on
the ground yeah so another reason the
wife would be
give me that spider tooth give me it its
butt is for pincers you see that oh it's
the web thing nevermind I know much
about arachnids more of an insect guy
okay you're prolonging this I'm learning
how did you get look how dumb it is oh
yeah Wow I was kidding I just need to
stay near its bud looks like ketchup
like so does real blood doesn't what
next stab me it's like they were making
regular resident evil and then they just
paid that guy to say zero and added it
on he was like yeah they just cheaped
out it was so fun to save again it was
so fun and a great idea to put cross
just what I and the many others who
watched love about the show I'd love to
have worked hard on it no you did a
really good job it was short notice I
was like hey if you can give us this to
us in a week that'd be awesome tomorrow
it was like five days so is awesome Oh
unfortunately I guess I'll just have to
make up for with revelations which will
mark ten seasons of cable that's weird
maybe so happy seeing how you liked it
though I'm very thankful I can make it
also we all love butts and she'll never
mess up an opportunity to draw a good
butt butts
oh yeah you were saying she exaggerated
my hindquarters
she definitely did come on alright so
now that I know what to do
should I go into that room again it's
kind of annoying but like I never have
been into that room yet
the diary there was nothing in there
though it was a weird room the diaries
the only thing in there interact you
could interact with the diary and there
was like I've no clue what time we
started this Emerson you haven't been
paying it no no no I'm saying I don't
know what time we started the episode
wait you're not gonna get those this
time I don't get those again you got the
red one this guy
so that's part of those just that oh
[ __ ] I took the wrong I have the wrong
person
okay yeah the way all right so let's do
a quick convince and then exchange okay
I think we're good except for she really
doesn't have a lot of bullets no she's
there are you crazy sir alright so we'll
just go in that room shoot those zoms
real fast and then individually we go
into the spider dad it's gonna be harder
for the second one cuz they're gonna be
off the ceiling also take that into
account maybe go with the Rebecca first
okay
there's two doors so which door should I
go into interesting maybe take advantage
of the fact the second one might not
fall from the ceiling and do the first
door with Rebecca the first work time
through I made any sense at all I forgot
[Music]
okay
yeah it's weird there's like nothing in
here I already read that and then
there's a box
whit's with gadgets and gizmos that's it
yeah that's weird
it is weird so we cheat a little bit
quick just so if we make sure not
missing shotgun shells or something yeah
I mean it's like there should be like
definitely something else in here but I
didn't see anything I'm gonna I'm gonna
do spider time and then you let me know
if I miss something
yeah so there's nothing relevant this
room just a waste of ammo hey I'm at
least I don't want to use to walk
through the whole time I know but I just
restarted yeah well we're fine we've
we've dealt with worse what's the lowest
point in this series do you think was a
resonable 3 in this series ever I would
actually say it was when we had a fight
no I mean like game heads of the boss
well interpersonal yeah that was bad but
the game
[Music]
yeah I went the wrong way didn't I big
dumb idiot so easy to get confused in
this game um I would say the lowest
point ever for me was there's an entire
episode where you tried killing the
Nemesis that was it sucks too because if
you were just playing the game at home
and that happened you probably would
have kept playing until you succeeded oh
[ __ ] call it I forgot to tell him not to
follow me I don't think they come down
until you uh go downstairs so you could
leave them up here you think I think
that's dangerous I feel like that's
risky risky and he might shoot them
which I don't want good point
I'll go yeah yeah yeah that's fine you
think you're so great and go
if she gets poisoned I don't have any
herbs yeah just go they're still not
even off the walls oh that didn't sound
good that does not sound good and I
don't have a lot going for me here just
leave what do you think that was
hopefully something poisonous
I don't know it's squelchy though what
is it
coming closer no it's not gonna chain
that your feet will get out here I don't
like that everyone cockroaches I can
shoot those now they were the problem
with handgun what do you want me to do I
don't know do you have something more
yeah I guess so do you have oh I know
Malta so no here here's my idea do you
think if you leave her in here and
switch to Billie and come down here
they'll note it well they haven't
noticed you here yet it's risky yeah but
exciting I raise that we're doing yeah
but you should turn her attack off
because already she's gonna be waste all
that ammo and dying IRA put Idol on I
guess is the right okay is that I don't
want yeah and I switch to him and get
here fast this is very risky okay okay
go [ __ ] what's he gonna do anyway just
having two people there will increase my
spread out the ammo distribution [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay well unless she got hurt do I
even get notified if she gets hurt I
don't know
so he needs a couple more bullets what
do you think yeah
I just want to clarify okay guys here we
go
I didn't mean to do so he's too full so
he couldn't have done that so I had her
do it
I serious yeah yeah as you know you knew
what you're doing I know I know what I'm
doing for Isaac all right hope this is
worth it because there's something shiny
there wait wait wait
she's stolen I don't like that she is
still an idol that's why you're here my
job okay she's gonna start shooting [ __ ]
yeah
no oh wait tell her to follow you first
oh right she's gonna [ __ ] die
do something shitheel [ __ ] sake
why is how is she fine now oh she I
killed her
where were you I was watching the
trailer you
I thought you paused on a panic I healed
her she's fine then yeah whatever let's
hope that item was worth it oh they were
eating their friend
good that's hot what is this oh it's a
key okay sweet no fire motif probably
right you have water
he's on coffee on okay so you need to
come in here you should feel better
about that you have a caution for Billy
is higher than I'll check out that key
you see where it is
key to a locker oh yes that is gonna be
helpful that gives you a handgun upgrade
okay so separate them yeah because they
have to go to there all right but I
don't know if she's safe in there alone
and she has eight bullets nine maybe you
go with Billy first thing okay
oh wait what you should be fine
no why because I'm reading something
that's old
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
um you'll be fine I think going Rebecca
first but you're definitely gonna need
both of them obviously at some point at
the same time cuz I would just have her
follow me and just go yeah you could do
that I think the spiders are still on
the walls let's regroup Roger yeah I'm
gonna have them go together and I'm
gonna I'm gonna do double Jukes oh yeah
you can I'm gonna doubled you good I
feel good about it I feel good
uneventful
just the way I like it how's your
margarita it's good it's almost gone
yeah um
should we do this together wait did your
mother wrong you go no it's upsetting
for you I've never been here okay yeah
okay sorry it looks a lot like the
bottle there's a main room and there's
an upstairs
[Music]
who has the I'm pretty sure you want
Rebecca up the stairs Billy is gonna be
in the [ __ ] in the lower room but do
they have to be split I'm pretty sure
yeah it's like a puzzle anything in
death huh
give the key to Billy if he doesn't
already have check it out Roger he does
not he has motives in health maybe give
those extra grenades to or just drop the
extra grenades for now yeah just drop
those she does nothing okay she could
take that grenades none just to have him
more no no no I see what you're saying
um I meant like she's in danger maybe
give her those other three molotovs I
could give her the gun
she's got to get I honestly would give
you her the other three Molotov I don't
think Billy's gonna run into anything
that require my hops oh yeah maybe he
will though what kind of game is this
also if I give her these multi I don't
think I can separate them maybe give her
give her them all tops and even handguns
a good idea to I think wait shouldn't I
just put him down there yeah that's what
you're doing but he needs the key and
the gun is that what you said yeah just
take the other grenades in case with him
and then you're good yikes I feel like
I'm gonna die this could all be horribly
misinformed but I think you're good
pick up the grenades with Billy and then
you're good he's gonna go so we're gonna
do this one at a time yeah actually yeah
take Rebecca and go up the stairs first
first this way okay yeah I'll go alone
okay
Oh God Oh God okay good who needs those
I mean both of us but we can switch it
later okay why can't you use those mp5s
in the that would be really nice a k47
there
um PM so I could go downstairs and give
him some of these bullets and a gun if
you think well I still don't think he
needs the handgun okay you can blame me
if you die well I didn't bring a shotgun
it's not worth going back to get the
shotguns wondering what you should do
with these I just I can drop it later
I'll just take it for now cuz I'm not
full can you is there anything in that
cabinet let's find out oh that's the
that might be the key what that's crazy
sorry you scared me because I laughs
yeah it sounded like a creep chuckles
cries out oh my god
Oh should I press a button or not
mr.akash job um no don't touch unlock
the cabinet first if that is indeed your
real name yeah
sweet now whose handgun do you want
upgrade
[Music]
can I do that now
is there a clue around here at all I
need a code okay there's something down
oh I see
cartridges of Magnum I don't have a
Magnum I'll tell you for now is there
something in your journal about the code
for that like I don't want to look that
up if we haven't really earned it yeah I
mean I can do it later yeah I'm just
curious like maybe in your journal or
something about it yet no files or
whatever so I mean it could be anything
but
is no we've already looked at that hold
on back out
well I examine the case again like keep
rotating it it's locked no I know but oh
three eight five
who the [ __ ] writes the code on their
briefcase yeah have you ever used this
suitcase like that with wow this is
really weird deep cut from my life but I
promise it's relevant to today's we're
recording this on September 20th
Thursday holy [ __ ] this episode's airing
on my birthday Saturday happy birthday
it's not my birthday until people watch
it but if they're watching it right now
oh happy birthday yeah I don't like to
be one of those people that says my
birthday but it's isn't your birthday
week no I don't I don't really be part
of your birthday month my girlfriend
gets me stuff and that's like that's all
I want in terms of anyway my parents
anniversary is when we're recording this
on the 20th the only other suitcase I've
ever seen with those the three digit
dial codes my parent my dad had one and
the code was his anniversary of my mom
nine twenty see that's relevant story I
mean it's very convoluted but yes which
gun should I upgrade [ __ ] which one is
the one that has higher credit is it has
black whichever one because before I
gave it to her I was like remember which
one is which his has a black handle and
hers has a brown handle well I would
just say upgrade Rebecca's whatever one
she's using why because she has less
health so she needs better firepower I
mean that's the most logical or that's
the easiest way
it's done cool it is done I'm assuming
they just upgrades the critical hit rate
if it's the scope who knows I'm thinking
too logically about it I would say so
yeah Oh does he need bullets no are you
sure because I'm happy to give this to
him no he's good with what he has - the
magnum rounds I drop them he needs an
empty space so direct drop those
somewhere does she need an empty space
she's gonna be up here kind of like from
what I can tell she's overlooking the
room he's gonna be in she's gonna be
like overseeing things are you doing oh
he want I'm giving him a space coz you
told me to give him a yeah but I'd say
you know he doesn't need the handgun
he's not gonna be firing that but now
she doesn't have space you can drop the
Magnum rails you don't need to carry
them like she could just drop them up
there and you can once we figure out
what's going on yeah sorry she can leave
those now we're good okay and then he
wants these yeah oh I need to become him
I got it I forgot okay so I'm gonna
leave her up here yeah that's what's
happening take the gern odds come on
okay I'll check it out
okay good by me he doesn't have any ammo
as are you sure what
Wyatt like he doesn't have a gun
he's got the grenade lunch that's fine
yes we're good yeah we're good let's do
let's go I'm fine okay so do I need to
become her now right
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] just happened that
did nothing - is he is she okay up there
yeah I think so I can't get these you
said I need an extra space that for
those okay I think I hope this could go
wrong it's your fault if it doesn't look
so no no no no wait
where'd even cut he came from there yeah
I don't know I guess see what's that way
I don't know there's a button there
I know it's red first off figure out
what her buttons even do cuz I don't
understand me okay so I need help
yeah and do a button check yeah cuz I
that camera work did nothing wait you
even go through that double door yet did
you
what double door back out Darius what's
the Billy that lowered the center oh
okay
so what Dumbledore right there
that's spider down its what that's why I
was gonna say spider town I said oh and
then up the stairs is all right gotcha
okay cool so center button lowered the
center and raised the outside so left
button must lower left where am I just
check this out so now the right button I
would assume would lower this do you
want to do it should I do it yeah okay
now he's just trapped in there let me
see
Center button and we're like here no no
no where he was yeah okay I'm a little
concerned about my well-being here
okay so let's think this through if he
needs to escape quickly it's gonna be
center button and then left right you
need to escape quickly I don't know if
I'm saying it Center button in left
center button raise that last ring with
that last case you're gonna need to
raise that mmm-hmm if something's
chasing him I wonder if you can raise
the gate stud I hid right though wasn't
it it was right and then Center it's
probably worth checking before we do
anything drastic just to double-check
well couldn't I do left now or right now
what would that accomplish Oh
Center yeah that's my question I don't
know though because I don't know
anything about what's going on right now
yeah now that makes sense it's one less
thing to do but if he is being chased I
just have a whole still stops him
I think it'll stop him but you'll be
able to raise that and like maybe stop
something that's chasing him so Center
will come in here first no this is
already good I'd say like let me just
talk about this like what's this is that
Center no clue cuz that gets him out too
right no that's left I think that's left
thank you we should really know this I
don't know but he's got a yes that's why
I'm saying so Swit go in there with him
go in where it doesn't matter just I
just I just want him in front of that
one because the camera angles are so
stupid that I want to make sure I know
which one is so switch to her back on
press figure out what rumors that I
think it's left Center lowered the
middle to and Rose the outside works
yeah so they're not gonna allow you to
doing one thing so that was that was
left this is still free that's good then
I think that's the best you're gonna get
so let me ask you this though
so that button is presumably gonna raise
this right but then what you mean if I
hit if I ran here and she hit left this
would go back down correct I think so
you can try it that yeah logically
that's what would happen because that's
what just happened
this is scary I don't sorry I can't I
don't know for sure that something's
gonna happen I'm just assuming it would
this game has he has a [ __ ] grenade
launcher oh yeah so people recommend
there must be something about to happen
if someone told to press the button
she needs to hit left after he's through
here yeah but you need that though so I
know if something happens really fast
that's the priority what oh [ __ ] hunter
all right what am i doing I'm killing
the hunters I'd say yes yeah yeah
grenade launcher just [ __ ] [ __ ] it
out nice yeah nice nice
yeah only to eat good job
well she okay you can swear to check but
that went well mama who that's that's
[ __ ] motif Keys okay what should I do
I can't combine these can I know oh I
know
okay I was so those weren't sent those
are napalm I'll just drop these for now
right yeah I mean I have to I have to
come back or I lose two grenades
those are your Oh what's open yeah just
drop just drop those out there all the
gates are open
you're fine just drop what everything
checking on her okay I wasn't trying to
rush you understand yeah I feel rushed
sorry
Oh actually also check the the other
hunter room whatever it was that little
sure yeah it's hard to tell - because
you can't see in there alright
yeah you could just bring her down and
grab those now does she need to do
anything I think we're done in the
basement like you think about he got the
tablet you got that key assuming that
was the water key she's only got one you
might as well examine the key just so
you know what it is sure
water at me sweet so that's that's that
was the big thing plus you got the
tablet you need two more tablets but now
you have access to all the water doors
and I don't think you're coming back
down here so it's worth anything
everything sucks though because I can't
take everything
I don't think trying to like I don't
know if the Magnum is tied to some weird
like fire extinguisher thing not to
bring up painful memories but it's
definitely worth getting the magnum
rounds I'm with you I know come on
combine the molotovs again okay
sorry they need to be closer
okay okay so now she can take two items
so take this item take it take it so
help me God and their needs and then
we're good let's go dumbass okay episode
we're kind of close I think I think so
yeah so you got a bunch of big picture
things on that was good actually one I
think I thought this was gonna be more
stressful than it was but I'm glad I
killed it all right do you wanna have
them both Juke spines at the same time
yeah you seem to have gotten the hang of
it wait you get those grenades I wasn't
paying attention I was joking all right
so go upstairs take a right go upstairs
to the right upstairs go go go I don't
you think they're off the wall yet
[ __ ] idiot sorry poisoned I don't
know I don't think they're Vans yet you
get it off the wall
where would the show be without my comic
genius
you should check if she's blue I'm
afraid I blew myself oh she's fine she's
doing better than ever how do I get out
of here safe yeah I hope there save
pucks in here I can't remember I think
they're so technically if you wanted to
not that it would make literally no
difference it just might've saved you a
space you could have come back down in
the basement later to get that tablet if
we knew that was there right matter
well the tablets in the main room it was
past the the animals you lit on fire
yeah but I moved it I took it right
right it worked out regardless I'm just
saying like that was at this moment I'm
that was less than us it started in the
water key although that's eventually
gonna be necessary so it works out
mm-hmm
just enough ink ribbies you know a few
in the upstairs though how many deals
left I don't remember that many I feel
mean you have more than just this never
I feel a little weird saving twice per
game I'll tell you that right now I feel
like that's good I feel like every time
we save twice an episode I'm like I'm
gonna run out I think you worry too much
I do worry a lot cool no I'd take those
you're not gonna come back down the
basement you're all set down here well
this doesn't save so all right all right
you figure it out then happy birthday
Thanks this is for a year I finished my
drink it's plural me drinking is your
birthday present
well every day is my birthday in that
case
I'm just kidding I do drink everyday no
all right good idea
sweet okay well I Bray as always thanks
for joining have a good rest of the
weekend is today the 22nd so I'm trying
to think we have October November
December January 25th if I recall
if I were clack-clack is uh February's
after January no I know but January 25th
is resonable to remake I'm trying to
keep the show on track now so I'd say
we're about a little more than halfway
through this game I think revelations
one is revelry no no revelations 2 is
slightly ok do or die rain or shine
cherry pie pie in the sky we are going
to be playing resonable to remake when
it comes out so if we need to crunch on
like revelations - revelations do is
shorter but that's coop and like I told
you you're I'll be Cherie Birkin with a
flashlight
that'll be my role that make sighted
you'll be berry I'm not Cherie Birkin
wait Cherie and Barry
I'm a very Jill sandwich mellow yellow
berry
I don't remember no sherry all right
cool well anyway we'll figure it out
we'll make sure
maybe we'll have like because that'll
they'll be more people watching uh some
people have like I was talking to Lucy
today about maybe having guests on and
doing the studio who knows or just keep
in the normal format because people seem
to like it why fix with ain't broken
well you're broken no fixing you anyway
thanks everybody for joining
as always we'll see you later thanks to
all the useful you drill people Nathan
Shepherd thank you for your stats Ava
thanks again for your art Nico thank you
for your tips everybody who's always
been around what you doing Oh am i
dragging or
I'm gonna end the episode with Mike
talking